ma chi è che ti faccio solo il cosplay e
lo zombie ma se lorenzo fragola è la gt
ragazzi mi metto questo video sono fatti
cosa stai facendo non lo so cos'è li fai
gola di prima non ho fatto niente
hariri fa è che giornata schifosa lo sai
che sono 14 ore che non mi lavo i denti
ma secondo me anche le braccia non tele
la vida 14 dubbio che siamo su the
forest lui e anni fa la cura di essere
famiglia che mi ha messo un messicano
anima la febbre benissimo anzi realtà
guarda verso io ho il montello delle
malattie dai mi piaci così essere
malissimo
sai che sembra comunque anima visto che
alla febbre parte con meno vita di me io
sono abbastanza si è messo bene
interessi per forza non è il pranzo
andiamo via dandolo trovati o favi il
prezzo giusto rispetta che io caccio
tipo katniss sembra zio ma io ho
lasciato un sacco di vivere ma ci sono
anche per te perchè me li sono mangiati
tutto si scoprono cose
l'alleanza non è più un alleanza ci
faremo la guerra per il resto degli eps
di mi faccio il mio popolo di digerito
il tuo ma è la peggior until ero
trovarlo e sempre cos'è quella roba lì
cosa seguimi tua roma rossa la tv un
boss una card non a caso a sé andare
subito a vedere non lo so andiamo tipici
andiamo questa chicca buttato breve va
bene chiaramente qua ti dà
un'indicazione c'è un'indicazione che
lasci scappare dalla vastità del cazzo
me ne frega è enorme meraviglioso mystic
perché c'è un container sarà pieno di
pasta di fagioli c'è qualcosa c'è
qualcosa ha trovato dello sporco trovato
dello sporco cosa dell orco poi c'è la
webcam quella che abbiamo ordinato ha
comunque a veloce la nuova scheda nvidia
vi serve che così registra medie imprese
apprende vedi se c'è anche l'ergatolo
direi che possiamo iniziare guarda che
ci vogliono forte le provviste di amazon
bastardi bastardi
[Risate]
perché sai cos'è questo no come su
questi sono i giganti li ho visti
giocavano a pallavolo
manca la rete anti manca una rete qua
campo da beach volley ma si possa dire
veramente non salire si può salire sono
diventato nathan drake che aiuta poi ci
suicidiamo perché la vita ora c'è la
palla ma sul serio una palla corrente
c'è la parata in di spero che la prendi
e la natura della lancio al volo prendi
la ci sei mai
sei pronto vai successo è buono qualche
a buttare è una gara a chi urla di più
equa e con i gol schifoso sapete che sta
andando a cercare aiuto mi sento ma va
avanti
mica l'abbiamo triturato grandissimo che
squadra lorenzo
pronta la cena grazie mamma vieni
torniamo a casa fox
cos'hai fatto oggi fatto basket e vado
forte o catturato gli indigeni mamma si
sicuro che questa cena sia commestibile
perché non l'ha detto ma tu lo sai che
se primo gif al drop guarda c'è una
caverna aspetta che metto un segnalino
diventarlo
questa volta no no vediamo io ho
sbagliato a fava oddio cresce tutto
perché va bene dai allora ascolta un
attimo io direi poi in teoria ci
dovrebbe essere vabbè aver storto la
capanna no ma la capanna non è nostra
quello problema che abbia già trovato un
posto da degli indigeni sì ci penso io
dove sei cosa fai ma non può andare con
un bastone allora vuole dire famiglia e
fa perfetto abbiamo questa bella
bistecca quella buona
iori ma la gente la vecchia e vabbè mi
faceva quanta gente
lo ammazzo ii iii campora del fuoco poi
morto è morto questo ci sei
dice un altro ancora chiama sei un
killer due ne sono altri cosa sta
succedendo e molto anche questo è morto
sono morti tutti siamo forti l'altra
gente pratica abbiamo da mangiare forte
ho dato fuoco impara per sembrano è
rimasto che arrivano quei due di
indigeni ce ne stanno arrivando altri
due lontano al 32 si aspetta che gli fa
ci penso io lo re non sta funzionando li
stai attirando sarebbe affatto pista
facendo che ha garantito veramente si
guarda anima che sa parlare indigeno e
fa scappare gli indigeni 4 c'era un
altro cervo ammazza la mazza lo bravo
[Musica]
non prendono lo dici tu me lo prendo e
basta è morto come hai fatto a prenderlo
itunes un sasso sopra dello scat pelle
di scerne bravo bravo sasha bravo fascia
abbiamo da mangiare fordo quando quello
si attiva la modalità del mood
sopravvivenza bisogna essere cattivi ci
sono i magica c'è un magic harp il
giocatore non lascia mickey adesso
stiamo facendo ci siamo appunto casa
tiri di farla prima che scenda che dire
di sì sei allora innanzitutto prima di
fare il punto casa bisogna assolutamente
fare fuoco perché sono fugazi che
sopravviviamo ok ok a posto dal fuoco ma
è così io chi è ma nessuno dovrebbe
scassà o cazz e si spera il dio allora
pesce o carne cosa preferisce milady è
un pesciolino berlino ma l'amica
briciolo nei fashion in cucina vai
qualche anno craco può accompagnare solo
cosa perfetto è che io userei
addirittura di fare già la cabina ora
che siamo messi veramente bene da
cambiare ma dico la roba e magari magari
alcuni sono nomadi noi arrivano magari
con la mania
ok esatto nel dubbio ne facciamo poi
un'altra che ho visto che banca soltanto
prendere i legni grosse manca ligny
grosse esatto vuoi buttare giù qualche
albero e adesso arrivo per tua lettera
inizia a buttar giù vai vai così ma è
così che siamo forti se facciamo un
accampamento figo qua abbiamo vinto
tutto ed è tornato il vero c'è un tipo
con la torcia se l'ammazziamo abbiamo
una torcia alla cosa non fosse spiderman
sarebbe più facile ucciderlo ma la
torcia la in testa o dove grosso e
grosso ma muore muore
mi sa che schivata sua sei morto sei
morso quando stavo io fermo e che mi ha
mai cantato che ti sapendo in quello di
esattissimo ok ti ho tirato su la zio mi
ha dato tre cartelle mike tyson è stato
grandissimo che stavano il filone il
calapranzi ma va bene entriamo dormiamo
dormiamo vieni a dormire e bella cuccia
sociale torinese e l'opportunità la
coperta solo addosso esatto grazia di
dio ce l'abbiamo fatta
ok se dovrebbe essere mattino in teoria
che gioia allora le ho fatto un ponte
che va beh abbiamo fatto di farlo bene
però è tipo cosa caxxo grazie ho fatto
un ponte perché quindi davanti ci
facciano la casa sul lago secondo me
[ __ ] la casa sopra raramente nel mondo
facciamo e le mura facciamo le mura
esatto quindi famiglie limitare soltanto
con le mura dietro testa di minchia che
palle no sto morendo nov hanno ucciso
anche a me no non si sa anche a me io
volevo semplicemente dire che volevo
mettere la cintura
sì e diventate un mero accordo perche
sugli sono forti ma insomma visto che
c'è una voragine quando viene a lei
guarda qua facevo un buco enorme ma che
questo buco gigantesco è il sedere della
terra porca [ __ ] lei ma l'iphone è
visto che c'è un buco ma che lei quando
c'avevo un buchetto come se fosse una
una cosa per andar giù una ad una grotta
ma che cazzo è questa roba qua dovesse
tipo da quando gioco a the forest in
tutti i venti episodi io non ho mai
vista una roba del genere ti preoccupare
sei anni ma l'esploratore cazzo il culo
e gli haters no ragazzo via mentre qua
dentro bellissimo ma ci sarà un modo per
calarla certo che ci sarà ora c'è un
buco in fondo rag anima ha trovato la
cosa della vita
comunque non è bellissimo ecco problema
sai quale è come cazzo scendiamo e
servono le funi le funi beh ragazzi
sappiamo già che cosa andremo a fare nel
prossimo episodio già capito tragica
fine del gioco il boss finale enorme il
no ma non ci sto credendo mai c'è una
roba ci garba vicino a casa nostra a
vedere con che questa roba qua in teoria
no vabbè ma poi lanciarlo quanto figo
guarda guarda
e questa in fila facciamo così per
scegliere chi cucina
chi colpisce prima l'altro allora la
nostra nuova in teoria dovrebbe essere
un perfetto preso ce l'abbiamo adesso
che abbiamo la nostra roba dobbiamo
farmi solamente recinto che così a meno
capisco come delimitare quest'area e chi
cazzo ne so non lo so ci chiamò ha
colpito sam bastardo 26 sono stato io
sei stato tu a ok poi se non muoio a
posto tu sei comportato giocata perfetto
ma io ce l'ho fatta fatto ho fatto il
materiale messo anche sopra si perchè
secondo me ha ragione secondo me si
buttano giù quindi io l'ho messo anche
per sicurezza per il massimo lo togliamo
come ci stanno buttando giù casa
bastardi ti giuro stato nel culo primo
tronco ha posto il recinto è finito non
ho assolutamente fare un effige più
grande
temiano miliardi di leva bene l'ho
finita quasi però mancano tanto braccio
e tanto tessera e test e test e test e
dove al quale ho messi troppo altro che
bello andare a mozzano
va bè ragazzi allora abbiamo fatto un po
di casino per arrivare fino a questo
punto però il principio di villaggio c'è
ci sono tipo siamo ora le basi recinto
l'ho messo tutto intorno in teoria non
dovrebbero entrare ma se entrano
dall'acqua a lungo fino a qual
allunghiamo abbiamo costruito la mini
casetta il fuoco poi lo facciamo
abbiamo quasi finito l'effige quella più
grossa è sparato un cervo che non
suscita uccidere come ultima cosa
superfiga secondo me dovremmo fare la
casa sul lago però quella la facciamo
poi dopo
ricordate che dobbiamo anche scoprire
che cos'è quella voragine e ci andiamo
sicuramente del prossimo episodio niente
ragazzi spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto se avevi è piaciuto non si
lascia documento è un mi piace ai capace
di facebook come tutte le iscrizioni
sono radicate ci vediamo il prossimo
video e ragazzi